people struggle with patients because
mainly most people are insecure
they worry about what other people think
about them so they're rat racing quick
to get the paper so they can buy
something to impress people they don't
even like and I'm trying to change that
narrative
number what's good
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks for coming out Gary thanks for
having me
in your life can you see that both of
them how they've kind of shaped you and
stuff my parents are very different
um
but obviously have a lot of similarities
I think my mom just deeply overloved me
you know in a way that's
just profound to me in hindsight I just
thought I could do anything I thought it
was capable of anything I was
you know purely loved but she did a
great job she held me accountable I was
a terrible student I got punished and
grounded so loved me but she didn't love
me in a way that made me think that
there weren't consequences I think
modern parenting struggles because we
don't hold kids accountable and so she
found that balance my dad scared the
[__] out of me my whole life even though
he didn't do anything about it like
meaning he never did anything to do it
it was just my mom used him as the bad
cop plus my dad has these weird eyebrows
where they're always mean
like so that was scary but my dad was
huge because when I was 14 and I joined
the family liquor store business
he really taught me some great
principles especially like your word is
your bond he's a very honorable
businessman if you say something you do
it and he he really rounded me out at a
time where by 14 I really had the Gift
of Gab and I could sell [__] and to me
the only thing that I cared about was
selling the thing the lemonades the
sports card and I think my dad caught me
at a good time and really taught me good
principles and so I was very fortunate I
am very fortunate I'm
my parents were 22 and 20 when they had
me so we're not you know once you become
like 30 or 20 even 20 you're kind of in
the same general ballpark so I have a
great friendship with them but it's none
of this modern [__] like my parents are
my parents you know I was very I'm I one
of the reasons I'm comfortable being so
out and about about everything I do but
including my accomplishments is I
actually am not very attached to my
success when when I hear that pre that
video that just went up like you're this
you're a marketing everything I hear I'm
like that's for my parents that's my
parents like they built me I'm the
product of them
so I'm uh I'm very proud to make them
proud and it's a very big currency in my
body
how do you how do you react to your
success today doesn't make you feel
proud how do your activities
how do I what my friend react I don't
think being a good businessman
deserves any
different treatment than any other
person
I'm extremely uncomfortable when people
give me credit for normal [__]
like there was some guy in the airport
in SF in San Francisco on the way here I
met him took a photo we talked he's like
man
you're really nice that's [__]
amazing
and and I know what he's saying and I
get it and I I don't feel comfortable in
that I I feel like money and fame and
don't change you I think they expose you
and so I'm I'm detached from the brother
like I'm proud of it I've worked very
hard nothing nothing I love when people
are like you're lucky I'm like you know
nothing about me like I'm very proud of
My Success
but I give a lot of credit to my parents
I give a lot of credit to the
circumstance
and I definitely don't feel like it
makes me special
I'm humbled by the attention I'm humbled
I mean
do you know what this feels like like
when you go to the complete other side
of the world and many people want to
come and interact and consumer like this
is humbling I appreciate it I really
have a lot of love for all of you thank
you for being here
But to answer a question in a different
way and then we'll move on I'm gonna die
one day
maybe I'll get some good action for 24
hours on whatever the way we communicate
digitally those days and then everyone's
going to move on with their life and I
think being grounded in that humility
and understanding that even if you
accomplish special things
the world will move on the day after
you're gone I think it's actually very
liberating for me
um and that's how I think about my
success
when you were building one libraries
thought did you ever know you're going
to make vaynermediate was that honest
later on
I feel like very early on I wasn't only
thing I thought about was I'm gonna
build a big company for my parents
because I love them I didn't even think
about myself and probably until my late
20s early 30s when the company got
really big and my dad was still paying
me nothing I was like this might be I
was like this might be a little [__]
up
foreign
you know when I tell kids to be patient
like I was I worked 15 hours a day six
and a half days a week
for 10 straight years and my dad never
paid me more than 70 000 a year and I
built a company from three to seventy
million
so I would have been way better off
getting a job somewhere else they would
have paid me a lot for doing that
um but I knew but I was 34 years old I
started vaynermedia with my brother AJ
and we had so little money because I got
so little money though I had some
savings but I had just invested in
Facebook and Twitter I bet the farm on
it
we started vaynermedia in the conference
room of another company because we
couldn't even pay rent and I was 34
years old
you know when I was 30 how many people
here are under the age of 13.
like when I was 32 I was stocking
shelves in a liquor store
so you can imagine when 26 year olds
come up to me and they're like I'm
[__] finished
I'm like [__] you haven't
started
so people struggle with patience because
mainly most people are insecure they
worry about what other people think
about them so they're rat racing quick
to get the paper so they can buy
something to impress people they don't
even like
and I'm trying to change that narrative
people that are kind of starting from
scratch how did you get the first time
in beta media what was it
well the reality was
I I really believe in asking like you
know you can just ask like especially
today
like if people are just starting and
they need a customer you post content
and you DM people
like when people people always like Gary
I can't get a customer I'm like how many
people did you hit up on LinkedIn how
many people do you cold email and how
many people did you call DM yesterday
the answer is always nothing
and in reality like for me it's just
like what if you want something why
aren't you not asking you don't want to
be annoying you don't want to be a Spam
bot but if you don't ask you don't get
and so you know for me it was asking I
mean mine came a little bit different
because I was already starting to build
a brand and there was definitely people
coming to me but
you know the reality is that it's just
very easy to ask in today's environment
I still believe for most people putting
proper content on LinkedIn speaking
about your expertise and or passion
leads to an incredible amount of
business opportunities and most
youngsters don't even think about
LinkedIn because it's a Tick-Tock
Instagram world and I I highly recommend
this room get way more serious about
LinkedIn content because the
opportunities of Business Development
are extremely strong there even if
you're selling a fitness app or t-shirts
or banana pudding like it's not a B2B
environment it's B2B environment but it
has people in it and people buy banana
pudding
so when people see you do so much
content how you speak it can almost be
overwhelming if we are communicating yes
that kind of entrepreneur what should
they actually go about it well maybe you
shouldn't be communicating in video form
I mean there's a lot of you that I've
seen your videos you really should not
be doing this
but you might be great at writing
like the written word is dominating
like you could take a photo of something
and then write a [__] three paragraph
Banger and accomplish the same thing I
can by speaking or maybe the camera
throws you off but you are a good
speaker and maybe you should be using
the Memos app on your phone and then
putting that over an image so there's
many different ways to communicate or
maybe you can't do any of them you can't
speak you can't speak on video and you
can't write then you get a partner who
can
there's always an answer
but I love when people like Gary but I
can't communicate this is [__] up I'm
like well I can't play basketball and
I'm not saying it's [__] up that
nobody's paying me 40 million a year to
play basketball
like there is no [__] up there's Merit
if you're not good at something you
shouldn't be compensated for it
and the reason there was so many
laughers that I brought let me give you
the Insight we are living in the
greatest era of entitlement in human
history
the reason everyone just laughed earlier
in clap now is something happened let me
tell you what it's called prosperity
it's been so good for so long in
Australia and America and Europe and all
these parts of the world of course not
for every person of course but the net
and so for some reason people just think
because they're breathing air or [__]
should happen
[Laughter]
that goes into parenting
for a lot of parents here they don't
realize paying for their kids lives is
[__] it up
if you're a parent in here and your
child is over the age of 22 years old
and you give them money bad things are
happening
when it comes to when it comes to
building a bigger business so many
people have almost a money mindset and
they can't they're not deserving a
certain amount of money for you
as as money mindset been an issue at all
or does it just seem like a bright parts
of your byproduct
yeah I mean money's good and all like I
understand what it is
um
as a kid I really thought one day I'd
really like to make a hundred thousand
dollars a year I had a number
you know I got there and you know really
you know
look I think it's tough to be like you
know every time I post content and I
post a lot of this content about the
money thing versus the happiness thing
people lose their mind they're so mad at
me they're like [__] you sure you can
say it because you're like I get it it's
just the problem is I just know way too
many people with money that are
miserable
you know and so you know for me I got
very lucky
and this is where luck comes in for sure
I love business I did it as a kid when I
was five and six and seven and it's the
summer the most fun thing for me was to
sell lemonade or wash people's cars like
I like the game
um I also think similar to we're living
in a great year of entitlement we're
living in a mirror where people have put
entrepreneurship on a pedestal and a lot
of people are forcing themselves to be
honors when they're not
let me remind a lot of you in here as
you go through your journey the number
six of Facebook and the number 12 is
black and the number 17 at Uber made a
lot more money than the number one in 99
of companies
you have to be self-awareness is what
leads to happiness not everybody should
be an entrepreneur it takes a real
stomach to be an entrepreneur
it sucks to be an entrepreneur
everything's your fault
everything's on you
like I wake up and people like what's
your morning routine I'm like I wake up
and look at my phone to make sure the
world's not on fire
because my Singapore office is open and
Australia is not like like it's constant
anxiety you gotta like it for not to be
anxiety but if you don't like it and you
were not built for it it [__] is the
worst and I watch entrepreneurship eat
up people every day
even the babies now
your message is as
trying to change lost inside the Joe
Rogan podcast says more recent podcast
interviews how do you what do you
think's been the biggest fish in in you
personally for the last six seven years
to me I'm a reverse engineer of what I
think is valuable to talk about
you know like if you talk to my friends
one of the people that know me best like
I'm I'm in the same pocket
you know in 2009 when the economy was
melted in 2008 and the internet was
starting to hit this scale it was
important for me to talk about the
opportunities after work
like of course I'm going to talk about
what's available to people from seven to
midnight when 99 of the emails and DMS
I'm getting is I lost my job what do I
do
right now I talk a lot about mindset
because 15 years ago I didn't get emails
about anxiety and depression now every
DM I get is that so you start thinking
about different things I didn't talk
about entitlement
you think I said that thing earlier
about if you're paying for your kids
life at 22 is to harass people I'm not
here to razz I'm here to give love I'm
saying that because the number one thing
I see that people are struggling with is
when they think their parents don't
think they're capable and the number one
way the kids think the parents don't
think they're capable is they're paying
for their life
parents think they're doing something
good they're doing something bad the kid
believes that you don't think they can
do it
and a lot of parents do it because they
want to show other parents that their
kids okay and they're doing well when
they're not that really want to really
[__] up a kid
buy a BMW for them not because you're
buying a BMW for them but because you
want other people to think they're doing
well but you and the kid both know
they're not doing well
so like I the biggest difference is
society is different I'm in the business
of talking about things that I think can
bring value
and so I'm following the conversation
and then trying to bring value to the
conversation from
my perspective to the best of my
abilities
and right now where's the conversation
going towards AI
you know I think a lot of I think
there's a lot of conversation I think AI
is definitely in the conversation from a
very technical standpoint
I think
you know I think people are tired
of the fighting
you know I think there's a fatigue in
people canceling each other that's
definitely a conversation I think people
are just tired of like the conflict
um I think people are
trying to find their niches
um
I think I think
there's a little bit of you know
generational Warfare going on
the Boomers versus gen Z thing is
[__]
fascinating
um but I think there's a little bit of
that
um I think boomers are sitting on gen Z
way too much especially since they
created them
I think gen Z is [__] on Boomers too
much without realizing they haven't
lived life yet and it's really cool for
you to tell everybody how to live but
you're 17 shut the [__] up
um so there's some of those
right like yo you should be doing this
I'm like you were [__] your pants
five minutes ago
what's one of the what's one of the
biggest mindset Chiefs you had to make
over the last few years
I had a real kryptonite in my happiness
which was
strength that ended up being my greatest
weakness I had to learn how to deliver
Candor to people that I love my Candor
on stage right now is off the charts
when I'm not talking to anybody directly
this is all day
the second you are even shifting from
acquaintance to friend my ability to
tell you things that I don't like
started to disappear if I love you I had
nothing to say I was just going to make
it good for you and so I really
struggled with that and it really led to
a lot of resentment when you can't
articulate things to people you start to
resent and that really caused me a lot
of all my pain and my personal life and
my professional life the single reason I
wrote 12 and a half was to talk about my
inability to be candorous and to talk
about this concept of kind Candor which
has really worked for me and is working
for a lot of people that are reading the
book and understand the concept which is
can deliver critical feedback or even
something potentially that sounds
negative it was something I had to go
through how did you start to improve
that skill set because
you're about
the same way people go about getting
into shape you go to the gym
begrudgingly the first time and you feel
like [__] and you can't do [__] and it
sucks that it's the worst
and then you just go back the next day
and it's a little bit better and then a
year later you're in the game I started
making myself uncomfortable once I
realized it because it was subconscious
for so long once I became conscious to
me
I
just knew that I wasn't going to be able
to
live
a life where I had now become aware that
I was bad at something and I was going
to sweep it under the rug that would go
against every way my chemicals work and
so I
just started practicing
what what's the current state of
personal branding in today's world do
you think some people say saturated for
their Marketplace how do they kind of
stand out that's today mentality
well it's definitely not too saturated
every day people are popping off the
reason people say it's too saturated is
they're not good enough
I love when people like yo here's my
favorite DM yo garyvee I'm [__]
Shadow banned
it's not oversaturated it's competitive
because now more people know the game
exists
You Stand Out by bringing value
the biggest thing I see every day is
most people post from a selfish place
follow me like me buy my [__]
I I think the easiest way to stand out
is every single time I post something on
social media the only and this is real
talk the only thing I think is why would
this be good for anybody
it's why I never show any parts of my
life that are not about what value
is a post that you see of somebody
boarding a private plane
what's that doing for you
everyone's well when I razz my friends
about it they're like oh it makes it
aspirational I'm like for like three
people the other four billion people
feel like [__]
so I think that it's not saturated I
think there's more tension than ever yes
there's more competition if you want to
break out you've got to ask yourself why
is it bringing value to people
like why is this post valuable and I
think all of us if we opened our phones
right now and won the stream you can see
it as clear as day the first 10 posts
you look at are not valuable for you
they're valuable for the other person
which is why most people aren't
sustainable
and what about the self-esteem to be
able to be like well maybe because many
people think they're not good enough to
post anything so how's them and tell
your mindset around self-esteem building
that
well now you're getting to the most
interesting [__] I mean I think that's
a big deal like self-esteem is
everything to me like I think parents
number one
number one job
in the world is to build non-delusional
self-esteem in their children
89 of us the person that made you
insecure is your mom or your dad and
that goes into some deep ass [__] which
is why I'm so happy that the stigma of
therapy is going away during this
generation right for all of us that are
sitting here every one of us that are
sitting here right now no matter the age
your parents lived in a world where no
one talked about therapy or you know it
just had crazy stigma if you want to go
see a psychiatrist you are crazy the
fact that we are so fortunate to be
living on Earth where that is now not
the case is huge how does how does
someone build the self-awareness to help
to kind of become more vulnerable with
the team and with their staff members
themselves
experience
I think the more things don't work out
the more you're like what do I have to
do to change
I mean vulnerability is a superpower
and everybody thinks it's a weakness
it's a superpower like every like
there's nobody on Earth that's perfect
and I think people should lean into the
vulnerability and it's hard for Alphas
male and women
um but I to answer a question directly I
think I think the Reps when you see your
[__] doesn't work three four five
times in a row you get to a Crossroads
where you have to make a decision am I
going to live in a delusional state with
my own self or do I want the success
that I'm trying to achieve and I think
if you if you believe in the Merit of
the game you start conforming to the
truth instead of your own delusion
and so yeah what's the latest through
the bay frames that you said you want to
like build the next almost Disney have
you always had that Vision or is it kind
of conversation I've had it for a long
time I you know for the last 10 15 years
I've wanted to buy an intellectual
property
I thought it was going to be something
like Scooby-Doo or the Smurfs
The Snorks which was this weird Smurfs
underwater in 1984.
Alf was something I was trying to think
about buying
so I was really hot on it for a while
and then when nfts came out I saw it as
a platform to be able to launch an
intellectual property a year before
covid came out I came up with this
concept I started working on called
workplace Warriors which are going to be
little toys to put on people's desks
because so many of the DMS that I was
getting
were coming from people upset at work
and I noticed at work and I'm sure all
of you know this in the office is people
have little toys on their desk or little
statues and I was like if I make patient
Panda or empathy elephant maybe when
they're having a bad day they look at it
and it makes them feel better and I was
excited about building this toy brand
I dragged on the little while coven
happened that killed it and if T's
happened and I kind of refurbished it
rebranded it as be friends and built
this universe I now think of it as
Pokemon meet Sesame Street
you know
there's a lot of like Pokemon to it
because I'm very hot on competition I
like the the friends competing with each
other the card game that I made which is
like a magic the Gathering Yu-Gi-Oh
Pokemon thing is very based on this but
the Sesame Street part is early on I
called it Disney but then as I got more
educated on Jim Henson and what the
purpose of Sesame Street is it feels
much more in tune to what I'm trying to
do I'm trying to make these characters
popular because I realized that I
have been able to build an audience and
I resonate with a lot of people but
there's a lot of people I don't resonate
with many people here who went out of
their way to be here today which is very
humbling also have a friend or family
member who thinks I [__] suck right
and so I can't resonate with everyone
but be friends
can and so through animation and movies
and coloring books and toys and pajamas
and backpacks and Candy I plan on
building this property for the rest of
my life
um
more trades that you have are you think
you think it's self-love
nobody's been able to ever say anything
that has veered me away from how I feel
about myself ever for even a second
now that doesn't like I think I make
mistakes every day I think I have bad
days I think I have bad weeks I think I
have bad traits
but I've never felt that I suck
like and nobody's been able to ever
convince me that I'm back you know and
so that's been huge
um
hard work
like tenacity matters
like if you're going to build something
real like you're going to have to put in
the work I love how people realize that
in health and fitness but then try to
make pretending business that there's
some sort of system
like
you know
there's no passive way to get muscles
I mean I guess you could get [__]
like AB implants but like
and yet people keep thinking there's a
shortcut my favorite bro is all these
Fitness people that start businesses who
all their Fitness contest is there's no
shortcut for putting in the work in the
gym and eating right and you've got to
eat properly in your protein ratio and
you got to eat clean and they go all the
way there but then right away they're
looking for a shortcut in business
you know and so I think tenacity I think
self-love I think curiosity here's a big
one for a lot of you that I don't
think's talked enough about I think a
big reason I've succeeded in a lot of
things that I see in others working is
curiosity
too many people say no the like watch
this no [__] please Melbourne please
don't [__] me it's okay this is not
like a rad session
I just want you to raise your hand if
the first time you heard about AI
no way that's bad raise your hands raise
it high higher
that I think about a lot the actual
point is there's almost in my opinion
one of the great missteps of opportunity
is being in the business of no
if all those people would attack the
information something new with at least
maybe
I think that would be very fruitful for
them in life to me knows and yeses
should actually be met with maybe much
more often
right so like the same people that just
raised their hand that said no to AI
20 years ago said no to
cellular phones
you know people said no to email people
said no to cell phones
how many people here had a Blackberry
raise your hands
do you remember when the iPhone came out
how you were like [__] that [__] I need
my buttons
how many people here have a Blackberry
with buttons right now that they
actively use
you know how many people here said they
were never going to be on social media
you know any people in here said they
were never going to be on tick tock
I've always been in the business of
maybe
I've learned a lot including the 99 of
things that end up being no I learned by
just going and exploring it which helped
me understand the yeses
for a second sir
you said no one no one else can really
impact
yes
the people in the room that don't have
that kind of self-esteem yet how do you
how do you respond emotionally to a bad
comment or a Halo how do they respond
mentally
I mean I the way I respond in the way
that I would ask you to debate is I
respond to those comments with empathy
could you imagine being a human being
that goes around the internet looking at
people's videos and pictures and
deciding to spend time to make them feel
bad
I feel bad for them brother
because they're in pain they're in a bad
place if you are in the business of
tearing other people down you were
deeply unhappy inside
so you know the next time somebody comes
on your page and says you're stupid
you're ugly you suck [__] don't feel bad
for you feel bad for them
like I've never spent the second trying
to tear other people down let alone
going around the internet to find
something to tear somebody down about
like you know and I understand that if
you don't have self-confidence it's
going to trigger you I think the more
interesting question I've been debating
for a decade is how do you build
self-confidence I think one of the
fastest ways is to cut out people that
are tearing down your confidence around
you
[Applause]
I think the conversation that needs to
be had are you going to limit your time
with family members to make you feel
that
like you know I'm not telling people to
stop talking to their mom but if your
mom is making you feel like [__] and
it's constantly complaining and
everything is bad maybe you don't need
to speak to her three times a day we
have to take on accountability and
protect ourselves and decide what we're
consuming
in life you find what you're looking for
if you want to find good [__]
you can literally open your phone right
now and find unlimited good [__]
people like the algorithm I open my
algorithm and it's like man saves boy
from the pond mom loves son
happy is good that's my algorithm
like your algorithm is exposing you not
trying to trick you
trying China's not trying to get you
you're paying attention dumb [__]